we will see a transgender olympian in my
lifetime someone who is out and
authentic with their identity and still
competing in sports at a high level
because now it's possible
my name is chris moser and i'm the first
transgender man to make a men's us
national team
my sport is sprint duathlon and duathlon
is run bike run
when i first started competing after
transition no one really thought that i
would do well everyone pretty much just
wrote me off because they looked at me
and thought oh he's a trans guy there's
no way that he can compete against men
hearing people say that really motivated
me to work harder to learn more to be
more dedicated to my training and try to
be the strongest competitor that i could
be
even though i made team usa i was
ineligible to compete at the world level
because of the international olympic
committee policy which stated
transgender athletes needed to have a
full lower surgery performed in order to
qualify
adding an extra body part is not going
to make me a faster runner or a stronger
cyclist
they just needed an athlete with a name
and a face someone who is actually being
impacted by this policy to look at it
and to say this isn't right the
international olympic committee changed
their policy for transgender athletes
and no longer have the same restrictions
they had before
i was so thrilled when the policy was
changed for myself but i was even
happier that the policy has now changed
for everybody who comes after me i will
not be competing in rio because duathlon
is not an olympic sport but i am so
excited to someday see a transgender
olympian compete on behalf of our
country what used to be the ceiling is
now the floor
you